ça fait maintenant 40 ans qu'on voit des
gestes étranges aux césars toujours ces
signes religieux
et si le cinéma français n'était qu'un
vaste complot peut déjà vous avez
remarqué
la cérémonie est diffusée sur canal plus
la seule chaîne avec une croix
catholique est observée dans la liste
des sept nommés aux césar du meilleur
film en les faisant légèrement glissé
une aux tirs bizarrement le mot apôtres
regardez aussi la fiche du film
yves saint laurent qu'est ce qu'on voit
très clairement et oui les initiales y à
celle forme parfaitement le serpent et
le pôle y ait de la bible mais c'est pas
tout si on écrit hippocrate et cilss
maria on obtient l'anagramme parfaite de
ici sera prophète islam et l'art fait
bien attention que désigne omar sy et
antoine de caunes sur la scène du
théâtre du châtelet
bien vu c'est exactement la direction 2
la mecque comme par hasard
d'ailleurs quel est le nom de la
ministre pellerin bah voyons
et puis le cinéma c'est quoi le septième
art bill poil comme les sept branches du
chandelier traditionnels juifs en plus
sur quoi sont filmés les longs métrages
sur des pellicules fujifilm fujifilm
c'est l'anagramme parfaite des films
juifs et pire nuit des césar c'est
l'anagramme parfaite deux sacs du
sentier coïncidence je ne crois pas et
les satanistes aussi et oui quand on
observe la statue à des césars qu'est ce
qui saute aux yeux bien vu on voit un 6
1 6 et 1 6 6 et 6 c'est le nombre du
diable prenez maintenant la latitude et
la longitude du théâtre du châtelet 48
51 et 02 28
en divisant 28 par deux ça fait 14 51 x
14 714 on enlève 48 et on obtient comme
par hasard 666 cela nous fait donc plus
aucun doute le cinéma français est un
complot catholico islamo judéo sataniste
alors qui tire les ficelles de toute
cette conspiration sûrement quelqu'un
qui règnerait sur le cinéma français
quelqu'un forcément très présent aux
césar regardez la fiche du film
bienvenue chez les ch'tis les revers de
la veste de kad merad sont clairement un
message caché et le titre du film
une simple modification et hop il
devient bien vous chez le christ est ici
qu'est ce que c'est c'est évidemment un
minaret musulmans et puis quand est née
dany boon enjoint 66 6 6 6 et oui c'est
un complot du président des césars lui
même maintenant pour vous pourrez pas
dire que vous ne saviez pas
et